I think the thing is because I'm this is
this isn't like my experience this isn't
my excuse me
not that I love more than [ __ ] I don't
take my favorite thing to do I'm a
YouTuber
one one obviously a lot of them have
been have been in the creative field for
a lot less time because obviously Tick
Tock hasn't been around for that long
yeah but number two like did you see
that article that were posted around or
that got shared recently about this tick
tocker who had like a million followers
I've talked about this like a billion
times yeah I know he's about the girl
she had like three million followers
yeah how to meet and greet Videocon no
one showed up yeah yeah yeah exactly and
it just I I guess it just I I guess that
that event alone just showed me a lot
about what it's like having a reach on
Tick Tock versus maybe having a reach on
other social media platforms because I
feel like with twitch I think twitch the
most I think that's where the audience
involvement and engagement is the
highest right because that's yeah
because you see the most of that person
yeah yeah so even if you have like a low
follower account on Twitch you might
have like the most hardcore fandoms oh
absolutely but I think Tick Tock is like
the complete opposite of that right
there's only so much of your personality
you can show in things how many how many
Tick Tock is by name do you remember
oh is she she is a person is she a tick
tocker I don't know so yeah I thought
about this right
you've you've probably watched like 30
to 40 tick tocks of a tick tock creators
tick tocks yeah
it's an actress
like 30 textiles from a Creator and you
won't remember their name yeah if you
watch two good videos from a big
YouTuber there's a good chance you'll
remember that of course yeah because
it's it's long form and like you know
you you're getting
someone to watch your Tick Tock 50 times
is still less screen time by far than
someone watching two hours of your
Twitch stream yeah yeah and it's like
you know you have to start looking at
what that means yeah in terms of
audience participation an audience like
are they going to buy your merch or
something yeah not that any any of this
is relevant to 99 of you but just thinks
it I mean I mean the same thing kind of
happened with like you know Vine for
instance like the only reason why we
remember are some of the bigger viners
because they've moved to YouTube right
and then they made a presence on YouTube
but like how many viners do you know
that didn't make that move over that you
remember my name no no no and all of the
big ones made the move over yeah they
all made their move over yeah because I
feel like with Tick Tock I don't know
singular creators I know them by like oh
there's that guy that did the the X
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
you're the guy that did the Drone video
yeah yeah oh my God yeah you know I I
don't like it like I don't actually know
the Drone guy the Drone guy like if your
name has no like power or no Brand Power
then like it's it's hard to like say
push your name and have it be advertised
on things yeah yeah you know be a big
Creator and stuff so it was a really
bizarre choice that VidCon decided to go
not that I'm offended I'm offended
um that they decided to go more for tick
tock is than usual position yeah it
makes sense yeah I think
the reason I think some other uh
Partners business partners that were
partnering with them were pushing for
more Tick Tock oh really oh okay if I
remember correctly is it because this is
the first year since like the whole Tick
Tock boom happened can we check on it
just Google like why is there so many
Tick Tock as a VidCon or something yeah
why are there so many Tick Tock I'll
tell you why can't it's because they're
relevant like if baton for like was
originally like YouTubers yeah like and
that's it was you know that was what it
was and then now it's like okay not not
really that anymore yeah yeah yeah
exactly there's still a lot of YouTubers
no they're also a lot but not as many as
before right I think yeah I would be
curious to see what twitchcon is like
because I really want to go but we're on
tour yeah
of course you would have gone
twitch streamer right whatever the most
degenerate con ever probably I've heard
so many horror stories [ __ ] yeah I heard
the Amsterdam one was fun though
well yeah of course it's an Amsterdam
Joey would like to go [ __ ] yeah not for
twitch guys
undisclosed reasons
okay so I had a quick Google on my phone
apparently the reason why there's so
many Tick Tock is is because Tick Tock
partnered with vidicom oh that's awesome
that's smart okay I mean that's why it's
small you tell me it's well it's smart
for they're pushing the YouTubers out
they're pushing the YouTube we're old
media now guys we're old media we are
the Boomers of Internet yes media I
already feel like that without YouTube
well you're just a burger
yeah
I don't know I I'm on Tick Tock uh Conor
Clips or maybe it's Sea Dog by now I
asked to have a change
as well as well yeah yeah and like I
none of us I don't think any of us think
that it's the future but I think it's a
good alternative I think for the future
you think it's going to be more
important than
as soon as they figure out their creator
fund I think the only thing is missing
is financial incentive once the
financial incentive is there there is
gonna be way more people I don't think
the money like adrav is ever going to be
there in in the way that it is on
YouTube Maybe not maybe not YouTube but
it's they definitely need a better
system than what they have now and when
they figure it out I think there's going
to be much more of a competition maybe
not to take over YouTube but I think
it'll be naive to say that it won't have
like a big massive impact here's an
interesting thought right
how so how would a say right now we're
going into a recession yay yeah
recession doesn't really affect
YouTubers that much as much a little bit
I mean it does but yeah hopefully it
doesn't affect them too much I mean I
don't know whatever but for tick tockers
and short form content creators it's
effects from quite a lot because think
about it
what's the one thing where you stop
getting money from when there's a
recession
as a Creator advertising advertisers
like yeah like sponsors yeah sponsors
stop buying ad slots because they're
like well it's all rounds it's not just
like sponsorships but just I mean you
still get address right but you get less
but you get a lot less but you'll get
less sponsored deals you'll get less
product placement that's the whole point
of a recession right everyone we made
the recession to stop YouTubers from
getting out here
how do how do current short form and two
Targets make most of their money product
placement ads yeah like that it will
actually affect them yeah more so like
right now it's like yeah you could argue
once it figures it out but now it might
be even harder of a time to get into
becoming a full-time short form Credit
content because there's a recession on
the horizon and ads aren't going to
start paying out money anytime soon yeah
but it's it's getting harder to just be
an online creative period like yeah what
platform it is yeah so I think
everyone's kind of in the same boat in
that case I I just feel like the numbers
are there it's it's I don't think it's a
fad I think that seems to be getting
bigger and bigger yeah I think the tick
tock algorithm is just too good it's too
it's good but right now how do you make
how do you put ads on it people are
going to figure that out well aren't
they aren't they are they going aren't
they extended are they gone yes aren't
they extending tick tocks to like three
to five minutes or something but then
the whole [ __ ] point of tick tock is
gone but that's what I was saying it's
like they're like oh I think that was
their way to combat like if you were to
have like a sponsored Tick Tock for
example or like an ad or like an ad
placement like or a product placement
for example that would leave the
creators more room right and if they and
if and if and if these creators now
they're like oh we can go beyond 10
seconds now we can go to like three to
five minutes that leaves more room for
ad Revenue to potentially go up all
right yeah so it's like I think that's I
think The Tick Tock by making these
changes they're trying to figure out how
to maximize the profits for these
creators without changing the Baseline
formula but that's hard because by
extending tick tocks to three to five
minutes you just have a YouTube video oh
[ __ ] at that 16 by what not what's the
[ __ ] I don't know what the full
weight there's a four minute I don't
know I hate that aspect ratio also I
feel like it's just much easier to shout
out something or to sell like a product
in Tick Tock you know where I mean
because it's almost subliminal with how
fast it goes look if if they could sell
Hustler's University on Tick Tock and
it'd be a success which it is then
anything could be sold successfully I'm
sure anything with enough marketing will
sell but yeah it's it it's that's like
the Rarity like a lot of people aren't
going to get a lot of money from this
stuff it's just not gonna happen I saw
one Tick Tock which is not religion to
the oil cannabis and it pissed me off
because it was just the dumbest [ __ ]
video it was a it was a I'm not gonna
name the drink because they don't
deserve promotion it was an energy drink
and this dude made a video like what
will happen if I pour this energy drink
in sand and then bury it
what and I was like
go on then go on I already know what's
gonna happen but [ __ ] you for even
thinking this is a good idea [ __ ] you
but did you watch it I watched it
because then it was gone I think it
worked it worked but I I walked it
watched it out of pure just like spikes
it's like watching a gorilla like you
just hate what yeah spy I'm like go on
go on [ __ ] do something interesting I
[ __ ]
all right and he did so what happened
what do you think happened Jerry did the
sand get wet the sand underneath just
got wet and then when he dug it up again
in five minutes it was just wet sand
what the f wait this isn't like I'd like
to think was this ironic no I'd like to
think this was like that's doing this
with other drinks I'd like to think that
he signed an ad deal that was like you
have to make this many tick tocks with
our product right he ran out of ideas
and the deadline the deadline was
literally like the next day
Portland's Channel see what happens it
was so dumb it was so it made me so
angry I was like this is a brand paid
him money for this a brand saw this and
was like I gotta put my my product on
this yeah dude they're gonna they're
gonna use that from now on they're like
dude if you if you don't like our drinks
you can just bury it in sand you're so
angry because I'm like you know you try
to you work hard to make these videos
online and you know like yeah man I hope
it's a good let's pull some [ __ ] Red
Bull and some sounds I hope this is a
good video and then you're like [ __ ] I
wonder what's gonna happen then it was
like never ignore these YouTube look at
these tick tockers man look at these
guys look at this content popping off
she drinks and sand like there's some
good some good
it's the same with YouTube really but
they don't pull like 10 million views oh
that's true yeah that's the other thing
is that they get views for some reason
oh no people just hate watching them
like you're like you they're like why
are you pouring this red ball into the
sand now I need to know I say out of the
10 million eight million of them were
people like I'd probably watch it as
well all the comments I'll get the
comments are more understanding in the
video they were just like you're a
[ __ ] idiot that's some of my favorite
tick tocks though some of my favorite
tick tocks is not the tick tock itself
it's the comments yeah like oh my God
Tick Tock comment sections are just a
gold mine Tick Tock comment sections are
like YouTube comments on crack you know
because because it's like with YouTube I
think we have more control over what we
watch because we have to click a
thumbnail and [ __ ] like that with
YouTube shorts and Tick Tock it's all
down to the [ __ ] algorithm we swiping
we're like why the [ __ ] was I
recommended this yeah you know and
sometimes they're like Facebook videos
they just kind of pop up exactly why a
lot of Facebook videos have amazing
comment sections because it's just like
videos you didn't want to see but now
that it's in front of me I have to leave
a snarky yeah because it's permanently
like with YouTube comments at least you
can like most of the time guarantee that
this content is going to be for the
audience you intended it for but with
Tick Tock it could be for any [ __ ]
audience you have no control over that
at all yeah yeah I mean the the more
recent Trend I've seen in YouTube shorts
recently it's just it's not is this even
a good Trend just taking [ __ ] movie
clips and just like this this tell me
this is fair use you take a movie clip
or a show clip yeah you put the sigma
grind set meme you put the sigma grind
set theme over it completely transforms
what the [ __ ] this is like the most epic
moment in Breaking Bad and it's like the
Heisenberg moment yeah and then he just
puts the [ __ ] Sigma behind set music
over I'm like this this is the problem
this is why none of you are getting paid
because you're all making [ __ ] like this
I I saw something that was even worse
like there's just like straight up tick
tocks that just take scenes from movies
and just add subtitles in the dead
center of it and it's like just 10
seconds of a random clip of a movie no
context explained is just like here's a
10 second clip and I'm like is it
transformative now because you added
some [ __ ] obnoxious subtitles that I
can't ignore yeah like like Tick Tock
has like no
does it have content ideas I don't know
technically you think YouTube shorts
would but I feel like I've watched the
entire season of peaky blinders through
uh YouTube shows except now if I watch
it and it's not got the sigma grind set
soundtrack on it then I'm gonna think
this is like this is this is fake this
is fake I wonder if like these companies
are just like turning their Blind Eye to
let their like short thing grow they're
just like yeah well it's like it's not
like they're getting paid and it is
exposure so I guess I will just leave it
kind of thing right yeah well we got the
I think trash taste our our Tick Tock
one got like it was like you you've got
a bonus money from your shorts channel
oh yeah the creative font yeah on
YouTube yeah on YouTube yeah right yeah
and it was like it was like I think we
had like three million or something I
don't know it was new views yeah views
no we have more than that was it we have
way more I remember how much we got from
it though yeah well I want to see the
views how many how many views and then
I'll tell you exactly how much we got
for what we got it for yeah just just to
show you guys just how little money you
get from I mean at this point like
reason we have a YouTube show is going
to take talk we have 63 million views
Jerry 60 okay 63 million views we made
about 600.
I remember I got the email I was like
boys will you let me do the honors claim
and it's like and it's just so
condescending it was like fireworks and
it's just like congratulations here's
your creative one 630 60 million views
and we made 60 million views we made six
hundred dollars
this is a good conversion rate good
conversion 60 million
it's so sad yo boys we eating good
tonight man we eating good tonight
that belly covers like our [ __ ] Uber
Eats costs for the week oh share between
all of gigs plus that's like what like
that's like a massier each yeah that's
like a material damn maybe we can pay
for lunch for everyone uh for all the
staff members yeah like that's the thing
right people don't understand like we
like you know when you have staff and
stuff and you have a lot of people in
your team helping you with production
and it's like oh well it's just doing
great our Texas is getting 60 million
views or something it's like yeah but we
can't [ __ ] pay anyone we can't we
can't do a business with this like it
just doesn't work yeah yeah we purely do
it just uh [ __ ] follow the truth yeah
the reason we do is because you know
it's we can afford to take a loss it to
be fair it is great promotional material
I don't even know if it is like I I
don't I feel like it's like everyone's
doing it I guess I'll laugh